fa migliore che se il barocco prova a
rubare delle banane a dei marocchini e
vedere che cosa succede
che cosa cazzo vuoi che succeda farmi
capire
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo in un nuovo
logo che i ragazzi prima che chiariamo
dove cazzo sono perché non è normale che
cambi sfondano i cinque minuti partiamo
con la farà della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da maria che ha
fatto questo disegno che è ricchissimo
solo che sembra che tipo che mario mi
stia prendendo a schiaffi tanto mi stava
già sul culo prima quindi no problema
che è ben non vediamo l'ora di fare sto
cazzo di blog per spiegarmi che diavolo
sta succedendo perché sono arrivato in
marocco tipo 45 giorni fa perché stiamo
facendo lo shooting del film quello che
stiamo girando e siamo letteralmente
all'interno di uno studio
cinematografico enorme che sta a
marrakesh in marocco è praticamente di
tutto ma le piramidi le sfingi deserto
gesù de riesco durante il video lo vota
di infiltrarmi nell'armeria a rubarle
armi vedere che cazzo succede se riesco
e tu questo ragazzi volevo ringraziare i
passando alla seconda news sarò breve ma
volevo ringraziarvi di cuore nei primi
tempi il mio libro the imbrogli né su
amazon è praticamente il libro numero
uno in italia arriva è già primo ragazzi
ma insomma davvero avevo già fatto un
discorso tipo su facebook c'è io non
sono uno scrittore ragazzi veramente non
lo so na quindi non mi ritengo tale ho
fatto questo libro perché racchiude la
maggior parte delle cose che ho provato
da quando aperto il canale quelle cose
che mi sono successe e l'ho fatto
veramente con i quei ragazzi ripeto non
sono uno scrittore ma allo scritto
veramente mettendoci tutto il cuore è
possibile quindi spero ragazzi davvero
che vi piaccia vi ringrazio per averlo
apprezzato così tanto non è ancora
uscito e già primo in tutte le
classifiche e assurdo vi lascio il link
nella descrizione se fosse interessati a
prenderlo comunque veramente vi
ringrazio niente spero che con il libro
io posso a strapparvi un sorriso come
riesco a strappare uno magari nei video
tutto paolo solo prendermi nativo per
ringraziarli perché è veramente assurdo
grazie di cuore passando ad altri
ragazzi sono contento che gli sia
piaciuta la serie di dragon ball che ho
fatto uscire ieri e non avevo idea che
piacesse così tanto veramente siccome mi
diverte un casinò sono stracontento e
farà anche altri episodi che aspettatevi
la distruzione totale proprio siamo
arrivati al momento ragazzi rho pero ad
infiltrarmi in armeria vedere che cazzo
trovo tenetevi pronti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ragazzi se avete bisogno di fare un
party giorno i fuochi d'artificio questo
tipo ragazzina arma di fallout pazze
pazze ska kat sim istante
matthew timmons quindi ragazzi siccome
siamo arrivati insieme qua non è giusto
che poi vi sono io le armi quindi gli
faccio iniziare con un qualcosa di un po
leggero tranquillo quindi venite con me
che mi insegna ok allora questa roba si
usa vi insegno io dalla prima si usa
questo credo sia il grilletto
credo che sia stata una cosa tragica
molto tragica
vabbè comunque ragazzi siccome tipo
questa è la mia stanza destinati lo sarà
per tipo 2 settimane perché rimango qua
due settimane per fare lo studio del
film voglio provare a far vj gialla un
attimino perché sono così è troppo
smorta prove da che cazzo riesco a fare
non so non ho idea e pro ci provo
[Musica]
ragazzi i pantaloni sono il tocco di
classe comunque non sa indicare le cose
ok
tipo all'altro giorno era in piazza
c'era una band che suonava fatto finta
di essere in discoteca davanti a tutti è
stato orribile
[Musica]
martin curley ragazzi seri marocco
shaman king arlidge 900 troppo sentita
al grop cazzo
ho avuto paura di morire seriamente e
quindi ragazzi detto come serie che
passiamo sera fa vi rispondo e che era
da un po che non lo faceva mi mancava
quali cantidad io giuro
grazie perché non farmi una boy band
tipo backstreet boys sarà da ridere io
sono lorenzo e io sono giorgio e siamo
in marrakech salsiccia
siete pronti guardo il cielo non vedo
altro colore solo grigio piombo che dai
dai dai
guardo il cielo non vedo altro il colore
grigio che io di te 2 fotografia tutto
ciò che rimane sul mio vero sogno letto
evento la distanza che ci divide fa male
anche a me
ovviamente no vai via qui sono
minacciati
[Applauso]
[Musica]
marrakech sausizza in live valentina ci
fa vedere la tua stanza adesso sei
proprio sicura non so se proprio in
ordine la mia stanza sarebbe questa
allora qua ci ho messo il computer
bellissimo perché la stanza tutta
esotica e poi c'è il computer a cazzo
queste sono cose che ho tolto dal
soffitto permetterci pantaloni erano
lampade una volta adesso accendi
pantaloni queste sono scelte come questa
è un set cinematografico enorme queste
sono scene di film attaccate al muro a
caso e poi c'è ogni album è tutta strana
dalla sta cazzo di camera la gasco c'è
una poltrona della madonna qualcosa c'è
un gran figo e se l'armadio qua ci
teniamo le cose tipo canzo cuscino roba
per pulirsi persone poi c'è musso
aspetto abbiamo il bagno che questo qui
c'è il bar in bagno e strano ragazzi
perché sembra tipo un bunker e tipo la
roba stranissimo è piccolissimo cioè non
ci caga neanche topo gigio qua dentro
prova per chi in marocco dividono il
cesso dal lavandino c'è questo è il
bagno dove c'è lavandino è questo il
bagno dove c'è eccesso sono divisi non
chiedetemi fottutamente perché ieri
conclude ragazzi cosa sono italiani
passare alla favi domanda e la fai
domanda di oggi è poi ragazzi attaccare
l'album di figurine il poster dell'album
di figurine il pantalone
a parte questa fa vj d'azione che ho
fatto cosa potrei mettere per rendere
più fa vj la stanza non si limitano ai
miei vestiti sporchi che sono sopra
quelli puliti
quindi sono adesso tutti sporchi che
bello quasi di sapere nei commenti
ragazzi così mi adeguo cerco di fare una
cosa decente è che i ragazzi se il video
è piaciuto ma se lasciato momento mi
piace anche a faccia di facebook economy
video tratta la descrizione se la
vorresti scrivete i cibi di euro
prossimo video bella ragazza